[Music]
there's so much we didn't know about
this place Henry world upon world entire
civilizations far more than we ever
theorized it's okay
[Music]
passing through we stake now claim
there
I thought I was going but that energy
from your hands how did you do that I'm
not the same woman I was 30 years ago
Henry this place it changes you an
adaptation is part of it but some of it
is evolution they did it ready to ascend
let's go see our daughter
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie you
probably just saw that Marvel confirmed
ant-man in the wasp 3 is happening there
are a lot of big plot threads after
Avengers endgame with the quantum realm
quantum energy and ant-man and the wasp
with the way they used quantum energy
that they still have to address as that
scene implies Janet Van Dyne is now an
involved being like you would think of a
mutant or an x-men character in the MCU
there's also a lot of Young Avengers
time-travel stuff that they're setting
up through Avengers endgame I'm still
doing the Avengers infinity saga giant
box set giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
your best theory about how they'll use
the quantum realm and quantum energy in
future movies so we just break this down
top-5 style careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen Avengers endgame or ant-man
the wasp but I feel like most of you
have probably seen those movies by now
number 5 as I said they confirmed that
they're doing ant-man 3 they haven't
confirmed what the title is a lot of us
are just calling it ant-man the wasp in
stature because Cassie Lang is still a
teenager right now as of the end of
Avengers endgame but Peyton Reed is
coming back to direct again making him
one of the first Marvel directors to do
an entire trilogy of movies himself next
to James Gunn
but guardians of the galaxy 3 won't
happen till 2023 I will explain the
release dates for everything in a second
- but a lot of people after the Marvel
phase for comic-con panel asked if they
would do another ant-man movie because
they have so much new IP because of
Fantastic Four Deadpool
the main x-men films in terms of box
office ant-man has always been one of
their smaller franchises just post all
your size puns in the comments both of
the ant-man movies have been great but
just in terms of actual box office
profits they don't make quite as much
money as some of their other IP and it
just seems like a new x-men movie a new
Fantastic Four a new Deadpool might earn
way more money than an ant-man movie so
Paul Rudd was making all kinds of jokes
after they announced their phase 4 slate
about them not doing ant-man 3 I think
just to get people worked up so that
they will start yelling at Marvel to
make a third film but number four the
reason why they need to do ant-man 3 is
because there are too many cliffhangers
involving the quantum realm and quantum
energy that they have to answer as of
the end of Avengers endgame we know they
perfected time-travel using it and also
as part of endgame time-travel we
learned that they can also use it to
travel between dimensions realities or
universes
in the multiverse technically all those
things aren't the same thing but you get
the idea they can use it to phase across
the multiverse and because of Janet Van
Dyne 'he's evolved body we know that
quantum energy has a lot of biological
properties you could even call them
mutant like abilities that they haven't
totally explained yet because they made
that movie before the Fox Disney deal
closed ant-man the wasp so that's why
she talked about it as being evolved she
couldn't say the word mutant Janet Van
Dyne just lays her hands on the ghost
stabilizes her quantum states so she
stops phasing between universes
uncontrollably but that's it they didn't
explain how that works or what was
happening exactly they're just leaving
that for the third movie so this is one
of the reasons why they're doing ant-man
3 before they announced their marvel
x-men reboot they keep saying that
that's a little ways off because there
are a couple big concepts that they have
to explain and as the name implies
Doctor Strange 2 in the multiverse of
madness you also get the teaser at
Avengers endgame in the first Doctor
Strange movie of the concept of multiple
realities ant-man 3 and Doctor Strange 2
we'll just explain those ideas in much
greater detail and use them as much
bigger story devices although obviously
Doctor Strange 2 is gonna lean more
heavily on the multiverse side of things
in ant-man 3 we'll just focus more on
the actual quantum realm of it all that
includes number 3 the very noticeable
quantum city in the background is Hank
Pym and Janet Van Dyne are leaving
during the ant-man the wasp I love how
they don't even mention it like Hank Pym
couldn't be bothered because he's seeing
his wife for the first time in over 20
years
janab and I just thinking about seeing
her daughter hope again but the real
reason why nobody mentions the quantum
city in the movie is because they were
just leaving it for the third film to
explain oh yeah there's a whole city
full of beings down there they're all
highly evolved just like me
Marvel has made some changes to the
quantum realm from the comics in the
comics it was actually called the
Microverse and it was populated by a
race of beings called the Micronauts
they have their own wars their own
Society they look kind of like
transformers but the reason why Marvel
can't use the name Microverse or
Micronauts
is because that's owned by Hasbro Marvel
just license them when they made the
original comic book so many years ago
all with interchangeable parts so your
child can create dozens of different
toys and when micronauts start a child's
imagination working he can create just
about anything
always the climb toys that spin toys
that float toys that stimulate young
minds I mean Mike but the basic concept
is still there you have a race of
humanoid quantum beings living in the
quantum city and maybe other comic book
characters that have the technology in
the science to enter the quantum realm
there's no way that hank pym is the
first person in the history of the
multiverse who's been smart enough to
figure out the quantum realm he's just
one of the only people on our version of
Earth in the multiverse that's figured
it out the whole concept of the quantum
realm is that it's a sub layer of
reality connecting all the different
universes of the multiverse there are
infinite universes in the multiverse but
there's only one quantum realm
connecting them all that's why the
Avengers can use it to travel between
realities like Captain America hopping
back to our reality after living out his
life with this version of Peggy Carter
and it's the reason why ghost phases
uncontrollably between universes until
Janet Van Dyne gives her a dose of
quantum energy to stabilize her at least
part of the movie is going to be
dedicated to explaining who those people
are down there and whether or not their
friend or foe there's also the people
that Sonny Burge talks about that he
works for people that don't take no for
an answer
there's all kinds of speculation about
how Marvel could tie that to Norman
Osborn in Oscorp there aren't that many
people on planet earth with the amount
of money that Sonny Birch's talking
about in organizations that powerful but
we've already talked about setting up
the concept of x-men in the MCU number
two this is where you also start to get
into Young Avengers Cassie Lang stature
King the conquer and more overt
time-travel stories Marvel and Kevin
Feige have only said that they're
working on a young avengers project they
didn't say if it'd be a movie or another
Disney Plus series but they have Cassie
Lang stature already Cherie the Miss
Marvel she-hulk and Kate Bishop Hawkeye
characters coming soon you can kind of
include Morgan Stark when she's a little
bit older if Young Avengers is gonna be
a time-travel franchise it's easier to
explain that an older version of her
from the future could join the team at
some point and if you want to get
technical you can't include spider-man
on that team because it's still so young
at age but really I counted more as a
full-blown regular Avengers team member
because of the events of Avengers
infinity war where Ironman
official kid Avengers spider-man
appearing in a Young Avengers project
would also depend on Marvel and Sony
renewing their sharing deal again after
the next two Spider Man appearances they
will but they're probably not going to
talk about that publicly until they
absolutely have to which is minimum
three to four years but number one
really important details release date
and characters so right now Marvel has
three movies dated for 2022 there's an
untitled Marvel movie dated February
18th they've already confirmed Black
Panther 2 is May 6th and then the third
film is another untitled Marvel movie
dated July 29th Michael Douglas just
confirmed that they start filming
ant-man 3 February 2021 meaning that
ant-man 3 is probably gonna take that
February 2022 date but get hyped up
about this the current leading rumor is
that Fantastic Four is going to be that
July 2022 movie meaning that they would
have to announce it and start casting it
and start filming it by summer 2021 I'll
do more videos about what's going on
with Marvel phase 4 when we get more
details but leave all your video
requests in the comments below there's
also a bunch of stuff starting in the
next couple of weeks as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see the videos when I post them
everybody click here for my new
spider-man into the spider verse 2
teaser trailer and click here for that
New Avengers 5 announcement thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]